vous avez déjà fait l'amour à 5 à 5
non c'est beaucoup
amendeur on a beaucoup parlé on va faire
une interview oui non et vous ne
répondrez à mandalir que par oui ou par
non
on ne bouge pas pendant le jingle
[Musique]
vous avez bougé
je suis désolé
on va faire une interview oui non
on est pas pendant le jingle
[Musique]
bien
Amanda Lear si vous trompiez votre Jules
est-ce que vous lui diriez non
est-ce que vous croyez en Dieu
est-ce que vous donnez dans la rue à
ceux qui font la manche oui
est-ce qu'il y a des trucs que vous
refusez de faire au lit
oui
j'ai moi-même je me suis autopié oh là
là j'aimerais le savoir
plein de gens aiment faire et moi par
particulièrement quoi par exemple
ces trucs plein les dents après
avez-vous réalisé vos rêves d'enfants
non quand même ça fait le plus gros
de la République femme tu aspires à
devenir enfin quand je dis tu voudrais
être
président un jour
non Amanda est-ce que vous avez déjà eu
des expériences d'inston sexe vous
rencontrez quelqu'un vous rencontrez
quelqu'un une demi-heure après vous êtes
dans les chiottes du restaurant pour une
demi-heure
tu es un raptus dans l'ascenseur
aimeriez-vous devenir Amanda lire la
maîtresse d'un chef d'État
S
c'est toi qui dirige parce qu'il fait
tout ce que tu lui dis
Amanda avez-vous déjà connu la
dépendance sexuelle
ça pose ça bouge et tout c'est
dramatique
est-ce que vous croyez à mon avenir
qu'il y a quelque chose après la mort
oui bien sûr ça fait la décomposition
vous avez déjà fait l'amour à 5 à 5
non c'est beaucoup de soustractions
les animaux
zoophilie Amanda lire avez-vous plus de
qualité que de défaut non
oui
y a-t-il un fantasme que vous n'avez pas
réalisé oui ma fille
en même temps mais en même temps
il faut de toute façon qui est toujours
un fantasme non réalisé parce que
attends quand on a réalisé tous ces
fantasmes d'abord on a plus que des bons
souvenirs c'est plus des fantasmes et
puis la vie est triste il faut toujours
espérer encore de faire quelque chose à
mon avis est-ce que vous vous aimez non
pas encore ça va venir ça va venir je
travaille là-dessus avec mon psy
justement
est-ce que vous feriez un film porno
pour un million de francs
non
non non tu m'aurais posé la question il
y a 15 ans j'aurais dit oui parce que je
trouve que j'étais encore
photographiable
maintenant
je trouve quand même des amateurs
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu